qu'on le veuille ou non le numérique
fait aujourd'hui partie de nos vies et
dans le monde agricole aussi il est de
plus en plus présent une de nos équipes
est d'ailleurs allé à la rencontre de
ceux qui préparent l'agriculture de
demain une agriculture qui sera centré
sur quelque chose d'intangible mais qui
vaut de l'or les données à qui
appartiennent d'elle à qui profiteront
elles voici une grande réflexion sur
l'agriculture numérique celle qu'on
appelle déjà la prochaine révolution
agricole
un verger quelque part en californie
[Musique]
ce robot cherche des amendes des amendes
à peine d'une maladie
ils les repèrent grâce à de puissants
algorithmes de l'intelligence
artificielle
il cadre son tir et les élimine une à
une le jour comme la nuit
bienvenue dans le nouveau monde de
l'agriculture numérique
les robots et l'intelligence
artificielle envahissent désormais les
fermes on assiste à une formidable
poussée du numérique en agriculture
nous serons 10 milliards d'humains sur
terre en 2050
comment produire plus de nourriture dans
un climat qui se réchauffe
l'industrie agricole propose
l'agriculture numérique pour augmenter
les rendements
et des géants et investissent
massivement
ça change l'économie agricole absolument
donc ce qui est vraiment nouveau avec
l'intelligence artificielle c'est la
capacité de prédire
[Musique]
making of
ce reportage est fait de questions des
questions quant à l'avenir de notre
agriculture
à quoi ressemblera cette agriculture du
futur
quelles sont ses promesses et quelle
sera la place de l'agriculteur dans
cette ère numérique
nous avons voulu comprendre comprendre
pourquoi le numérique est maintenant vu
comme la prochaine révolution en
agriculture
nous sommes au sud de montréal chez l'un
des plus importants producteurs de
l'étude du canada
nous voulons savoir où en est cette
ferme avec le numérique sans surprise
une armée de travailleurs s'activent au
chant
[Musique]
mais à deux pas de là contraste
un robot travaille seul celui qu'on
appelle la chèvre remplace six
travailleurs
donc qu'est-ce qui est en train de faire
actuellement au chant présentement le
robot savoie dans le champ de manière
autonome puis le 3o broeck sont
articulés qui utilisent l'intelligence
artificielle pour arracher les mauvaises
herbes
nous on est les sticks la meilleure
façon d'enlever les mauvaises au dollar
à chypre au final tous reportent les
robots faisceau aisément puisque leur
bouffer c'est qu'il reconnaît la
mauvaise herbe et le plan saint est
capable dans le temps j'ai vu la
mauvaise herbe donc je dois aller l'a
ramassée et larache et
discerner une mauvaise herbe d'une
laitue pour un robot ce n'est pas si
simple les ingénieurs ont d'abord
identifié sur des photos des laitues de
toutes tailles et des mauvaises herbes
de toutes sortes puis ils ont entraîné
les algorithmes du robot en lui montrant
des milliers de photos afin qu'ils
apprennent à reconnaître les bonnes
plantes et chaque jour le robot continue
d'apprendre plus recueil de la donne est
plus susceptible d'être précis
absolument c'est comme si en plus on
voit des images lui nous nous nous c'est
des interactions avec les gens les
interactions avec des photos convient
qu'on se rappelle des choses c'est la
même chose pour le robot
[Musique]
les rebonds sont un des piliers de la
révolution numérique en cours
en fouillant l'offre des fabricants on
se rend compte qu ils sont des dizaines
à faire leur entrée sur les fermes
chaque année
ils cueillent pulvérise dg d'herbicides
alors qu'un autre transportent des
charges
ils sont vus comme une solution pour
verdir l'agriculture parce qu'ils
réduisent les besoins en pesticides
l'autre avantage c'est l'économie main
d'oeuvre
[Musique]
ces robots sont porteurs d'une bien plus
grande révolution
sous le capot des caméras et des
capteurs collecte des milliers de
données sur le sol la température où les
plantes
ces robots l'os et comme ils naviguent
dans les champs pendant qu'ils naviguent
et accumule un paquet d'informations
région l'archevêque a travaillé pour
l'agencé spatiale canadienne en
intelligence artificielle
il connaît bien l'immense potentiel des
données massives ce que plusieurs
appellent le big data on peut s'imaginer
que la même information niveau de
bonheur on peut extraire d'autres
informations comme possibilités de
maladies possibilité d'insectes
possibilité d'autres problèmes peut-être
lui un froid
manque donc quelque chose comme seules
les données massives sont donc au coeur
de la révolution numérique qui est en
cours sur les fermes
pour nous autres cette année là qu'on
accumulant les conserve dans le cloud on
les conserve al interne ça vaut de la
rambarde
un autre pilier du numérique repose lui
aussi sur les données massives
l'agriculture de précision
elle a débuté il ya une vingtaine
d'années avec l'arrivée des gps mais
depuis un arsenal déjà connectés s'est
ajoutée sur les équipements
jean-françois ridel a pris le virage
numérique et demandez-lui aujourd'hui de
travailler sans ces outils
c
comme si on travaillait avec un oeil en
moins si on devait travailler toujours
comme ça là tout à coup on envoie tout
en 3d avec ce donc ça donne une autre
vision ça nous rend un peu plus
intelligent par contre on voit que des
zones qui sont venus que d'autres des
caméras spectrale installé sous son
seuil noir lui fournisse des données sur
ces sols chaque fois qu'il fait un
passage déposé ça va nous donner par
exemple
la température du sol ou même le contenu
de matières organiques dans le sol donc
on voit leur rien on le voit oui en
temps réel puis ensuite ça va générer
une carte donc on voit ici qu'il ya un
enjeu quelconque
puis on voit qu'il ya des zones où
est-ce que plus de carbone et moins
d'autres
le plus étonnant ce sont les cartes
générées par les capteurs ultrasensibles
qui mesurent la compaction du sol leur
précision est inouï on voit des
tracteurs qui ont fait un demi tour ici
pire encore plus impressionnante j'ai
une parcelle d'essai avec des chercheurs
et on arrive à voir les portes ou est-ce
qu'ils ont marché sur les billons et ils
ont été faire leur échantillonnage il
pleuvait ça paraît encore sur la carte
essence j'étais surpris d'arriver à à le
détecter la
[Musique]
les fermes serait-elle en train de
devenir une source infinie de données
numériques
[Musique]
une recherche rapide et permet de s'en
convaincre en europe par exemple on
estime qu'un seul hectare de blé génère
un million de données numériques par
année
la ferme du futur appartient donc au
grand nuage informatique
et grâce à ces données de jeunes
entreprises façon déjà l'agriculture de
demain
[Musique]
nous sommes à montréal ces ingénieurs
entraîne des algorithmes aujourd'hui il
travaille à partir de données
recueillies dans un champs d'oignons
cette jeune entreprise apporte une
solution à un problème fondamental
comment mesurer la fertilité des sols
quand ces nutriments varie un peu
partout aux chantres nous on a développé
une solution qu'on descend directement
au sol puis en quelques secondes
seulement on parle des résultats
vraiments la concentration chimiques
henson et nitrates le potassium le
phosphore
[Musique]
ces données sont récoltées grâce à une
sonde comme celle ci ce qu'ils prenaient
des semaines en analyse chimique au
laboratoire ne prend aujourd'hui qu'une
fraction de seconde
seule condition toutefois il faut que le
modèle digère d'immenses quantités de
données
on prend une photo de sol ils font
beaucoup de données de calibration pour
entraîner ses modèles là pour leur
montrer que quand on prend une photo x
une seule avec un spectre mais cette
variation spectrale veut dire une
concentration nutriments par exemple les
nitrates 2x de phosphore d y voit ça
prend beaucoup d'entraînement
les informations tirées de ces données
massives sont inestimables
elles permettent aux producteurs
d'apporter rapidement les correctifs là
où le sol en a besoin chacun des points
qu'on fait songer aux références et donc
le résultat final pour lui c'est une
carte avec l'ensemble de ces points là
géoréférencées avec la concentration
nutriments à cet endroit
en écoutant ces spécialistes on comprend
vite que sans la donne et agricoles il
n'y a pas de robotique ni même
d'agriculture de précision
on prend alors conscience de la valeur
que représenteront ces données dans le
futur
des entreprises l'ont compris et en font
même déjà le commerce les producteurs
réalise tous le potentiel de la valeur
de la donner ça c'est clair que non je
pense qu'ils réalisent nécessairement
c'est quoi la valeur de leurs données
puis comment est-ce qu'il doit devrait
être vigilant avec la gestion c'est d'un
lot qui finalement sont dans plusieurs
systèmes qu'on parle de systèmes
satellitaires qu'on parle de censeur sur
l'ensemble des équipements les données
agricoles sont l'actif de demain sur les
fermes
grâce à elle on pourra passer à une
agriculture encore plus intelligente
une agriculture dont les algorithmes
seront capables de prédire ce qui
arrivera aux champs
la donne et c'est les fondations pour
aller la prochaine étape en intelligence
artificielle en robotique avancée
accepte hamouma qui sait pas si ça va se
faire c'est en train de se faire c'est
aujourd'hui que ça se fait c'est la
réalité
e
[Musique]
vous avez sous les yeux une des plus
grandes régions maraîchère au monde la
vallée de salinas en californie
ici l'eau est indispensable et on
utilise à profusion
la californie qui est pourtant de
connaître deux des pires sécheresses de
son histoire
peu d'endroits doivent conjuguer avec un
climat qui se dérègle et la production
d'autant d'aliments
on s'est demandé comment laquelle il
fournit utilise le numérique pour
relever ce défi
[Musique]
l'université de californie à davis
cette institution réputée a récemment
lancé le chantier des grandes idées pour
trouver des solutions aux crises que
traverse l'humanité
la baisse des rendements agricoles
causés par le réchauffement du climat en
est un exemple
des villes slater est responsable de
chantier
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup d'occasions d'améliorer
l'utilisation des ressources
peut maintenant tirer parti de
l'intelligence artificielle et des
technologies alors qu'avant on avait pas
ces outils
l'idée c'est maintenant de trouver
comment ces technologies numériques vont
nous assurer d'avoir assez de nourriture
pour tout le monde
pour ce chercheur
la californie est un avant poste dont le
climat force désormais une agriculture
plus intelligente
pour y parvenir on doit miser sur les
nouvelles capacités a pris dire de
l'agriculture numérique
qu'on doit orienter l'intelligence
artificielle dans le cas des fraises par
exemple elle nous aidera à ajuster la
production à la consommation
elle aidera à prédire comment réagit le
fruit à la météo en plus de prévoir la
demande des marchés pour éviter
gaspillage
en mariant l'intelligence artificielle
ou données massives on va plus loin que
les simples cartes on pourra par exemple
prédire les rendements d'une culture au
moment de mettre une somme en santerre
ces systèmes intelligents sont aussi
capables de prédire les besoins andrew
un moment précis de la croissance des
plantes et selon la météo d'une région
c'est comme ce joueur d'échecs qui voit
toutes les pièces du jeu en même temps
l'agriculture de prédiction c'est
maintenant le saint graal de la
recherche agricole
et ce spécialiste est aux premières
loges de cette nouvelle science
[Musique]
son équipe mettent au point des systèmes
intelligents capables de prédire une
foule de paramètres dans les cultures
d'amande
il utilise des caméras haute résolution
et des capteurs qu'ils attachent sous
ces drones
ici c'est un majeur
la californie produit les trois quarts
des amendes cultivées dans le monde mais
avec le réchauffement du climat on
anticipe une baisse de production
d'aff
voilà pourquoi les modèles prédictifs
sont si importants ils nous renseignent
aujourd'hui sur ce que nous pouvons
faire afin de mieux planifier le futur
un demi-kilo de planning et
les modèles qui l'a mise au point met en
relation les données de base d'un verger
avec une foule d'autres variables comme
la consommation d'où mêmes l'exposition
au soleil de chaque arbre
ici nous pouvons voir un nouveau type de
carte on voit que les arbres du côté
nord sont plus grands pour chaque
analyse les algorithmes fouilles la
banque de données historiques du verger
le système digère cette information et
trouve lui-même les variables qui
prédiront le mieux la production
d'amande
[Musique]
c'est une carte de prédiction des
rendements
foncé les rendements attendus sont plus
élevés que les secteurs en vert pâle et
blanc cela montre une certaine
variabilité
ses prédictions permettent des gains
environnementaux
les producteurs pourront réduire par
exemple les quantités d'engrais
chimiques en fonction des rendements
anticipés pour chaque arbre
nous pouvons donc utiliser ce qu'il faut
dans grey de sorte que nous n'aurons pas
de contamination ni de détérioration de
l'environnement dans le futur relais
à notre grande surprise les outils de
l'agriculture prédictive sommes déjà des
laboratoires
fait la connaissance de terrasses nsia
un des plus petits robots du monde
agricole ils fouillent lille dessous des
champs de maïs
on a créé soit beau parce que les gens
lui demandait constamment de faire voler
des gros sous le couvert végétal comme
c'est trop difficile aussi dit qu'on
pourrait en faire eux qui roule au chant
ce robot viennent en aide aux compagnies
semences qui développe des variétés de
maïs
pour ces entreprises ce qui prédit le
mieux la performance de nouvelles
variétés se cache désormais sous le
feuillage
[Musique]
les capteurs du robot sont très près du
sol et donc près du plat nice ça permet
à notre logiciel de traitement d'image
d'analysé des caractéristiques
spécifiques comme l'épaisseur de la tige
et le nombre de feuilles par place
en comparant les données anatomiques des
plantes le système intelligent du robot
prédit les variétés qui donneront le
meilleur rendement
terrasse nsia roule aussi depuis peu
dans les immenses champs des producteurs
de maïs américain
il sera utile pour prévenir les carences
d'une culture pour détecter les premiers
signes de maladie
fournir aux agriculteurs de bonnes
informations à partir de données
disparates c'est l'un des grands défis
sur lequel beaucoup de personnes ont
travaillé jusqu'ici
l'agriculture a jusqu'ici été basée sur
l'observation
mais en mariant les données agricoles
aux algorithmes l'agriculture devient
non seulement plus prévisible mais elle
sera désormais beaucoup plus précise
nous aimerions exploiter les grandes
fermes commerciales avec la même
précision que celle que vous utilisez
pour votre jardin
nous voulons que chaque plan chaque
animal puisse produire à son plein
potentiel et pour faire ça
nous devons avoir une approche
personnalisée enjoy
[Musique]
cette agriculture plus précises ouvre un
potentiel gigantesque
c'est une tangible de cette excitation
la silicon valley s'empare de
l'agriculture
on a rendez vous ce matin avec une des
étoiles montantes de cette nouvelle
industrie
est un ancien de google il a tout quitté
pour fonder son entreprise
avec son équipe il travaille
actuellement avec les pomiculteurs des
états unis et son ambition n'a pas de
limites
alors que tous les bibliothécaires du
monde n'aurait pu le faire nous on
indexe des espaces physiques ces
ingénieurs se sont donnés comme mission
de suivre le développement de chaque
fruit comment en numérisant des vergers
entier en trois dimensions rien de moins
c'est comme être un premier scientifique
avec un microscope vous découvrez
soudainement un nouveau monde nous on
peut lui trouver une valeur grâce à la
puissance de calcul des ordinateurs
cette image a été obtenue grâce à un
système de vision artificielle
développé par les ingénieurs
en faisant défiler leurs caméras entre
les pommiers il répertorie dans l'espace
chaque branche et chaque bourgeons de
pogner
[Musique]
la compréhension complète du cycle du
fruit nous permet ensuite d'y associer
une
table où f
[Musique]
quand les caméras détectent trop de
fleurs sur un bourgeon les bus de cet
appareil asperges une hormone qui stoppe
la croissance des fleurs
cette précision n'est possible que si
tous le verger est indexé au centimètre
près
des ingénieurs voit même apparaître les
tout premiers signes d'une maladie sur
un fruit
imaginez vous ayez un agronome qui
surveille une pomme en particulier 7
jours sur 7 quand une mouche atterri il
la chasse avec une brosse qu'est ce que
vous feriez avec ça
quand on a un modèle numérique qu'on
peut ensuite utiliser la puissance de
calcul pour faire la recherche la
corrélation ou l'apprentissage
automatique
c'est une super puissance informatique
qui est d'aix le web
c'est maintenant une superpuissance qui
indexe la ferme
l'agriculture prédictive pour encore
gagner en fiabilité et en précision
mais avec la force de calcul qui
explosent et les données agricoles qui
ne cesse d'augmenter on se rend bien
compte que ce n'est qu'une question de
temps avant que ces outils envahissent
les fermes
balawi going down
certainement on va vers ça
jorion grippe
cela conduira la troisième révolution de
l'agriculture
le numérique change le visage de
l'agriculture et les sommes investies
témoigne de ses immenses promesses
en 2020 les états unis ont dépensé 12
milliards de dollars dans ce secteur la
chine 6 milliards
[Musique]
qui sont les investisseurs il y a les
jeunes entreprises de la robotique et de
l'intelligence artificielle
et il y a les fabricants de machinerie
comme john jr
john deere a commercialisé en 2022 son
tout premier tracteur autonome
l'entreprise intègre également des
capteurs et des émetteurs de données
dans ces machineries
mais la surprise vient des super
puissance du numérique comme google et
microsoft
google vient de lancer son projet
minérale afin de développer la robotique
agricole
microsoft quant à elles s'intéressent à
l'agriculture de précision et au
stockage des données agricoles
et le canada n'est pas en reste le géant
de la téléphonie telus vient de créer la
filiale telus agriculture la nouvelle
entreprise a acquis jusqu'ici aux jeunes
pousses de l'agriculture numérique
il est tout à fait logique que les
entreprises qui ont une expertise d'un
traitement des méga donné la
modélisation et les technologies de
pointe se lance dans l'agriculture
mais l'arrivée de grands joueurs
suscitent des inquiétudes
l'accès à d'immenses banque de données
dans un secteur névralgique comme
l'agriculture soulève des questions
éthiques
y at il un risque que de grandes
sociétés contrôlent l'agriculture grâce
à leur mainmise sur les données
[Musique]
une des grandes questions qui possède la
donne et la protection de vie privée à
la ferme sera importante et il faudra
veiller est ce que le système soit
équitable et que nous l'utilisions dans
l'intérêt de la société
pour comprendre ces enjeux on a rendez
vous avec un des géants de l'agriculture
la multinationale bayamon santos et sa
filiale climb cooperation
nous sommes dans le comté de sacramento
en californie
la performance de ces champs a été
suivie grâce à l'application développée
par climate cooperation
essentiellement nous aidons les
agriculteurs à utiliser leurs données
afin qu'ils prennent de meilleures
décisions à la ferme
cette firme est né dans la silicon
valley qu'en 2006
ses fondateurs développe un système qui
analyse les données sur les sols les
cultures et la météo
en 2013 leur technologie devient si
prometteuse que le géant monsanto pays
1,3 milliard de dollars pour acheter
l'entreprise
tourne autour des données massives les
agriculteurs recueil des données depuis
des années qu est-ce que je plante ou
est ce que je le plante qu'est-ce que je
pulvérise mais il n'avait tout
simplement pas les outils pour utiliser
ces données pour prendre des décisions
c'est ce que nous avons fait
en agrégeant aujourd'hui les données de
ses clients l'entreprise possède des
informations capitales sur une grande
partie des cultures aux états unis une
question s'impose alors à qui
appartiennent toutes ces données
les données appartiennent toujours aux
agriculteurs ce sont leurs données ils
peuvent les partager comme bon leur
semble aux entreprises avec lesquelles
il travaille mais nous nous n'avons pas
le droit de partager leurs données avec
des entreprises tierces
sur le site internet de l'entreprise on
apprend que les contrats oblige les
agriculteurs à partager leurs données
avec la maison-mère bayer do you mean
girls aloud
bailleur peut avoir des données agrégées
sur l'ensemble du territoire et non les
données propres à un seul agriculteur
so what the proper
le partage de données et seulement pour
alimenter les algorithmes ça nous donne
une vue d'ensemble sur toutes les
données massives ce qui nous aide à
mettre au point deux mers outils pour
les agriculteurs
[Musique]
n'irait que l'agriculteur n'a pas les
outils pour être maître de ses deux
mirage
[Musique]
sébastien picarda dirige une plateforme
de partage de données destinées à
protéger les agriculteurs d'europe
il déplore que les intérêts des
agriculteurs ne soit pas au centre de
cette transformation numérique
bailleur va vendre sa semence avec ce
savoir-faire qui a une partie de cette
valeur ajoutée issue des données des
agriculteurs l'agriculteur donne
s'adonner gratuitement
parfois sans avoir pris le temps de lire
le contrat de partage de données et
derrière va racheter des semences
améliorées
mais qui corresponde à un coût pour
l'agriculteur
son groupe a analysé plusieurs contrats
qui lient les agriculteurs aux grands
fournisseurs leur qualité est souvent
variable
[Musique]
un exemple un agriculteur peut rester
propriétaire de ses données mais son
contrat lui interdit de les partager
certains contrats n'exclut pas non plus
la revente de données
pour protéger les agriculteurs
le plus grand syndicat agricole de
france s'est dotée d'une charte des
bonnes pratiques
très concrètement
l'agriculteur quelle que soit la taille
doit pouvoir être libre et avoir la
garantie que ces données un ne sont pas
perdus 2 quelles sont sécurisés et 3 qu
ils les partagent avec les acteurs de
son choix
de retour au pays on est allé rencontrer
ceux qui ont mené la toute première
enquête sur l'agriculture numérique
qu'en est il de la propriété des données
mais on a très peu de balises en fait
sur le partage des données c'est
vraiment au cas par cas c'est
quasiment exclusivement contractuels
parce que souvent cette chercheuse a
aussi constaté que beaucoup
d'agriculteurs ne réalisent pas
l'importance de protéger leurs données
parce que c'est des données sur leurs
métiers leurs cd aspect tangibles en
fait de leur exploitation donc ça va au
delà du personnel ce sont des données
d'entreprise donc effectivement il ya
une méconnaissance de la valeur des
données et
et peut-être aussi une
une confiance aveugle envers les
équipementiers qui eux récoltent
énormément donné finalement
la chercheuse rappelle l'urgence de se
doter de règles qui protègent les
agriculteurs
mais les données agricoles dit elles
doivent tous y circuler librement pour
ne pas à être privatisées
actuellement de petites entreprises
manquent de données pour leur
développement il en va de la capacité du
québec à prendre le virage numérique
même s'il ya des dérives c'est
l'innovation qui va gagner en partageant
les données et en ayant des données des
données ouvertes après par contre il va
falloir s'assurer d'avoir des balises
qui encadrent c'est ce partage de
données la fin
de telles balises protégerait aussi les
consommateurs
les chercheurs s'inquiètent de la
spéculation boursière sur les denrées
alimentaires gras sous contrôle des
données agricoles
ça peut amener certaines personnes à
investir en ayant des connaissances plus
fine que d'autres dans la bourse parce
que souvent ils peuvent savoir si le
cours va s'effondrer ou si le cours va
augmenter et donc ça c'était des dérives
éthiques pourraient survenir
l'europe a fait le pari de faire
circuler librement les données agricoles
mais une loi encadre leur partage
pour sébastien picarde à la loi sur la
gouvernance des données est un rempart
essentiel contre la mainmise de grandes
sociétés sur l'agriculture
le risque est réel de privatisation
quand on voit les grands acteurs
multinationaux technologique ou
agroalimentaire investir des millions
d'euros dollars dans la transformation
numérique de leurs entreprises et des
services apportés à l'agriculture
les gars femmes américains montrent un
modèle économique basé sur leflux plus
vous utilisez leurs technologies et plus
elles génèrent de l'argent ce qui est
tout à fait sain mais correspond à une
vraie problématique
la france c'est le pays qui compte le
plus d'agriculteurs en europe
bien des fermes sont de petite et de
moyenne taille la france reste pourtant
le pays d'europe qui investit le plus en
agriculture numérique
quelle sera la place de l'agriculteur
dans cette nouvelle ère numérique
producteurs et consommateurs frontil au
coeur de cette révolution agricole
nous sommes à montpellier véronique
ballon morel dirige un groupe de
recherche qui s'intéressent au
développement responsable du numérique
en agriculture
aujourd'hui la révolution il faut la
faire aussi avec mais plus petit on va
devoir nourrir les villes est ce qu'on
cherche c'est de conserver une petite
agriculture
qui sera capable de produire en grande
quantité
donc il va falloir aussi planifier et
agrégé et 100 numérique c'est quelque
chose qui serait pas possible
les travaux de cette chercheuse consiste
en partie à doter les agriculteurs de
technologies moins coûteuses comme de
simples capteurs de données reliées à
des téléphones intelligents
pour moi la plus grosse révolution c'est
que grâce au numérique l'agriculture va
redevenir aussi attractive aujourd'hui
ce qu'on voit se dessiner c'est les
agriculteurs de plus en plus petit ou
des agriculteurs bio par exemple qui
utilise du numérique et on entend aussi
des femmes par exemple qui disent eh
bien grâce au robot de traite moi j'ai
pu reprendre la ferme de mon père
j'aurais pas pu le faire sans la
technologie
bien que la france embrasse le virage
numérique beaucoup de chercheurs
s'attendent néanmoins aux dérives qui
inquiète les agriculteurs
véronique ballon morel met en garde
contre la perte d'autonomie
la perte d'autonomie elle peut provenir
du fait que à partir des données on va
être capable de connaître ce qui se
passe sur la ferme et parce qu'on aura
de bons systèmes d'aidé à la décision on
va pouvoir piloter la ferme à distance
donc ce qu'il faut éviter c'est que
l'agriculteur ne soit plus là que pour
fournir les terres il est important que
l'agriculteur garde une autonomie de
décision
pour mieux connaître l'impact du
numérique sur les agriculteurs il faut
mesurer jusqu'où ira cette
transformation agricole
montréal pôle mondial de l'intelligence
artificielle
ici comme en france des chercheurs
s'intéressent au numérique responsable
l'intelligence artificielle existe
depuis longtemps thierry varin enseigne
la science des données ou va
l'agriculture quels sont les prochains
modèles d'affaires de l'agriculture et
ça s'en va vers l'économique plateforme
ce spécialiste parle de nouvelle
économie où les entreprises qui
possèdent les données développeront la
vente de services agricoles
donc je suis par exemple une grosse
entreprise qui fournit du matériel
agricole je peux très bien mettre une
caméra sur mon tracteur et du coup d'un
seul coup je récupère des données non
structurées des images de la récolte ou
du labourage de ce champ donc d'un seul
coup j'ai une cartographie en temps réel
de tout ce qui se passe sur les terres
agricoles de mes clients ça veut dire
que je deviens une plate forme je
deviens comme le google maps de
l'agriculture pour moi c'est une
révolution parce que ça change
l'industrie de l'agriculture au niveau
planétaire
l'économie de plateformes c'est le
modèle facebook l'entreprise collecte
les données de ses utilisateurs pour
ensuite revendre des services cette
économie de plateformes changera la
concurrence
les fournisseurs de matériel qui était
en concurrence auparavant ne le sont
plus ou vont l'être - parce qu'une fois
que vous allez acheter mais tracteur qui
sont équipés de senseurs qui vont vous
donner de l'information là vous allez
rester sur mon tableau de bord vous
n'allez pas prendre de chance à aller
sur un autre modèle prédictif d'un autre
fournisseur etc
[Musique]
l'entreprise de matériel agricole va
devenir une partie prenante extrêmement
importante alors qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le cas vous avez de la concurrence
donc si son rôle devient beaucoup plus
important la question à se poser c'est
est-ce que l'agriculteur recule un peu
dans cette chaîne de valeur donc est ce
que la concurrence sera toujours
à un niveau satisfaisant pour que le
consommateur et l'agriculteur soit en
position de force à
peut-être pas c'est un scénario en tout
cas qu'il faut considérer
le numérique pourrait donc imposer un
tout nouvel équilibre dans la chaîne de
production des aliments
pour bon nombre de chercheurs il est
impératif que les agriculteurs
conservent leur pouvoir pour des raisons
de souveraineté l'alimentation est un
secteur extrêmement important vital par
définition etc les agriculteurs qui font
la production
souvent les agriculteurs sont la partie
fragile de toute cette chaîne de valeur
mais mes fonds qui est cet équilibre
moi j'ai un principe qui est j'aimerais
que le gouvernement d'une façon ou d'une
autre et autant d'informations que les
grandes compagnies qui sont présentes
sur notre sol quoi
en rencontrant tous ces acteurs on se
rend compte que la souveraineté
alimentaire passe maintenant par la
souveraineté des données
avec les données agricole les
producteurs ont désormais entre les
mains un tout nouvel actif des
politiques publiques sont nécessaires
pour un développement harmonieux de
cette nouvelle agriculture
ne faut-il pas accompagner ceux qu'ils
nourrissent afin qu'ils ne sortent pas
affaiblis de cette révolution
silencieuse de l'agriculture
[Musique]